now during this election campaign I'm
going to be traveling around the country
and visiting a different constituency
every week and the aim is that we're
going to try and tell the story of how
this election will be won and lost
through four seats in particular that
you can shippi able to see just on the
wall behind me we're going to be going
to East Room for sure in Scotland
Cheltenham Kensington in London and also
great Grimsby these are four seats with
four very different stories behind them
and it was Grimsby that I visited this
week it's the seat that's held by Labour
but with a small majority of only two
and a half thousand and people in
Grimsby voted 71% to leave the EU in
2016 which means it's exactly the kind
of state that Boris Johnson and the
Conservatives are targeting early
morning at Grimsby fish market fifty
years ago the town was home to the
largest fishing fleet in the world today
the trawlers have all but disappeared
and many believed that the decline of
the fishing industry has been hugely
significant in Euro skepticism in
communities like post but Europe is only
part of the story the decline here
started when Britain lost its richest
fishing grounds during the cod Wars with
Iceland from the 1960s and today the
fish here are imported from countries
outside at the EU no case we've we don't
have an issue particularly with the
common fishing policy because we don't
have so many vessels landing fish
anymore our interests are outside of the
EU because Iceland Norway and Faro
are not in the European Union and there
are trade deals that exist so we think
the opportunity to continue bringing
fish in will just carry on nevertheless
the referendum here was 70% leave and
receipt is now a key battleground in the
general election the Conservatives see a
route to a majority through leave
supporting labour held seats in the
north of England places just like
Grimsby but this town has returned a
Labour MP in every general election
since 1945 and people here really ready
to turn their backs on generations of
tradition and elect a Tory the last
Labour MP feels most comfortable
targeting the government's record honest
as the way to ensure victory well the
main issues that people want to talk
about well of course
brexit is up there is the kind of top
political issue but they are also really
worried about what the last nine years
of a Conservative government has meant
for towns like Grimsby the impact that
it had on their own lives perhaps in
terms of their incomes perhaps in terms
of their safety perhaps in terms of
being able to access medical treatment
or getting support for their children if
they shouldn't got a special education
needs the Conservatives pour cold water
on this and believe the people of
Grimsby back them on brexit and that
other factors are in play people like
the fact that I'm a local candidate
they're really thinking carefully about
what they want to vote for they know
it's not just the bat brexit they know
it's about other issues as well and
people really do not want to have Jeremy
Corbyn as an ex prime minister and
that's really really focused in people's
minds they know if they vote for anyone
other than a conservative the likelihood
is that we'll have Jeremy Corbyn as our
next prime minister and people
absolutely dread the idea meanwhile the
brexit party believes they can advance
at the expense of both labour and the
Tories they fed up with the extremism
that threatened by in this constituency
Melanie on Corbin they're fed up with
that they fed up with it on the Tory
side as well and especially since what
Boris has done in bringing back a
reheated withdrawal agreement and the
Lib Dems believe they can capitalize by
sticking to the remain message it could
be very tired and I think with three
brexit candidates in the Conservatives
the brexit Party and the Labour Party
locally the vote is going to be split
that it could be split very tightly and
if we can attract the 30% of people in
the town they voted to remain to come
tours that will put us in the mix but
what did the voters make of what's on
offer
my family's labour but so my first
though was labour but since I have been
conservative and what do you think the
Boris Johnson
yeah look he's a bit out there he's a
bit extrovert and things like that but
behind his you know it's he's demeanor I
think he's got you know he's pretty
switched on I hope that labor or anyone
that Boris Johnson becomes Prime
Minister because I think it's kind of
just run everything down and made false
promises and nothing is really gonna
happen from his plans and his brakes
that a big factor for you yes because I
want to study abroad and what do you
think of Jeremy Corbyn I think he's
quite good some of the things he said
obviously haven't been that great you
know he's been accused of saying things
racist and you know antisymmetric and
stuff but I think some of the things I'm
doing is really good he's trying to
support young people more how did you
vote at the last election I asked you
voted in the last election and how you
plan your voting this time I'm really
absolutely torn I want I want to vote
brexit I really want to vote breaks it
but I'm not sure how that will go so I
think I might have to vote Tory just to
make sure that there's absolutely no
chance
I want a voted to leave and I've always
been a Labour I thought I don't mind
Jeremy Corbyn I don't think Mellie done
will gets him either
I think people have had all of of being
promised this that in the other she's
there to represent halls and she hasn't
done that Grimsby is a town in
transition the fishing industry that
once accounted for thousands of jobs is
long gone but the old fleet is now being
replaced by support vessels for the
booming new industry of renewable energy
attracting billions of pounds and new
investors we started in 2006 with very
small operation and that just developed
to the point now where I think it's
pretty much agreed that Grimsby is the
the main hub for offshore
for particularly for operations and
maintenance in the UK the big question
is whether Grimsby and other Tory target
seats will witness a sea change in
boating patterns if so a lift for the
Conservatives in these traditional labor
heartlands will drive Boris Johnson back
into number 10